what's up guys come see me on the road
right now go to savocanocomedy.com for
tickets uh April 7th I'm in Seattle with
the guys at the climate pledge Arena
April 8th at the Keller Auditorium in
Portland we have two shows the second
one still has tickets uh Bangor Maine on
April 27th the Wang theater in Boston
three shows April 28th and 29th that
weekend uh two shows are sold out so
this one show left to get tickets then
we go Maverick Center in Utah May 5th
Bellco Theater in Denver May 6th uh
let's see what else here then we go into
Texas we're going to uh Arlington Austin
at the Moody Center and Sugarland Texas
at the Smart Financial Center May 19 20
and 21 and just to round out this summer
right now these are the last dates I
have before the new dates are announced
there's gonna be a lot of new dates
announced soon so if you don't hear it
just check back but we got Columbus on
June 2nd Cleveland on June 3rd at the
rocket mortgage field house and the
Schottenstein Center respectively two
huge venues there the Fox Theater in
Detroit on June 4th June 15th we're in
Minneapolis uh June 16th Des Moines at
Wells Fargo Arena June 17th the T-Mobile
Center in Kansas City and the last dates
right now before we announce new who won
the ones Nashville Grand Ole Opry July
27th uh Cambridge Field House in
Indianapolis on the 28th and St Louis we
got two in St Louis on the 29th at the
stifle theater and one there's tickets
available so hope to see you on the road
Impractical Jokers every Thursday nights
at 10 brand new episodes right now on
TBS thank you guys so much April 12th
Austin Texas sold out April 13th San
Antonio we have a few tickets left May
5th the second show and buffalo has a
few ticks left May 6th in Ithaca
few ticks left May 7th Albany is sold
out Australia is on sale now we got
Sydney's on sale in June we are adding
Melbourne we are adding Brisbane all
those tickets at christycomedy.com New
York City Radio City Music Hall
September 22nd all sold out so we added
September 23rd the theater at Madison
Square Garden got a few tickets left for
that September 23rd New York City
christycomedy.com get some merch up at
christiecomedy.com if you're in the
Boston shows and all that the merch sold
out guess what baby those shirts are
available online they're really cool uh
Chrissy chaos shirts with the Boston
Celtics logo and we got new merch coming
my vice show every Tuesday 10 p.m super
maximum retro show watch the show I'm
going to start to I think live tweet it
or Instagram it
um because the ratings are not doing
well so christycomedy.com for everything
watch my show on Vice super maximum
retro show
[Music]
we must bring
Salvation back
Just Call My Name
hey babe how you doing I think we did do
that we did it but you know what if we I
feel like we did it two episodes again
if we did we did what we do is which one
did you like better this one or the one
from two episodes yeah because I
remember singing that from the heart
because when I sing even if it's these
theme songs I leave it all out there
right you do leave it all out there I
don't know another way can I ask you a
question I leave it all out there no
matter what I do you always do that you
always you can leave it you're a guy you
give it 100 you remind me you want
comedies post Malone
thank you so much I would say you're the
post Malone of Comedy you go 100 yes you
go all day every day and you like a Bud
Light I like a Bud Light and so I
suppose yeah I saw him on your
Impractical Joker show just with the Bud
Lights
you're a practical joker show
I do I have a show in Brighton Georgia
you know he the show's been great
practical jokers with the guest is like
the it's like another thing yeah I like
it it's different it's different it's a
Vibe it's a different thing and people
the reason it's been great is the people
that have come on have owned it a lot of
the people have been our friends a lot
of people have been people that we were
dying to work with already yeah well
that have come to us and like I've been
watching for 10 years yeah and it shows
and they come on it's just it's exciting
because you don't know we have to tailor
the bit to them right then you don't
know what they're gonna bring to the
table so the first week we had uh uh
with the first week we had Brett
Michaels lead singer of poison sure dude
by the way Brett Michael no relation to
Sean Michaels no relation to Sean
Michaels no relation to Al Michaels wow
right okay
Gianna Michaels
grateful and still look it up I know
Gianna Michael you know how she yes
she's been out of the Limelight but she
was in it for a while I know Gianna
Michaels big time
um so anyway uh so so by the way July
16th of this year he's playing the PNC
uh Brett Michaels and with with I think
to post Malone no Brett Michaels and
Paul Rudd was also on episode one
Ant-Man Ant-Man he just he just dipped
in and like it was like I'm coming on it
was a great episode him
the guys and I are going to be on stage
at the PNC performing with Brett
Michaels literally on stage performing
all the hits I literally think that this
new thing this what first one
[Music]
what a [__] name and guess what else
we're all wearing capes wow
you know what I think too with this new
Impractical Jokers format I have to
think that week by week the views go up
every week and that's when I and that's
what I think
I go up every week and if it goes up for
eight weeks
after eight straight weeks
I just want to see more of it yeah well
look to our fans right now they have the
option to pick up 11 they haven't yet
and we need good ratings and what I like
about it is also what I like because now
because a lot of times it wouldn't be on
True TV and then you're like damn and I
miss it well now it's on TBS it's on TBS
and true every week but CBS is a big
fight PPS is big I like I would care if
I saw it there all the time so what so
what I think they're doing I think every
episode's on TBS right now and I think
they want to see if we're gonna get
ratings on TBS and if they do I think
they're gonna move us over to TBS that's
what I think I think that's all the
ratings come from TBS and and it
literally goes up incrementally every
single week it went up it went up with
post Malone it went up last week with
Anthony Davis my mom was on last week
yeah
oh wait when is this coming out two
weeks so last week and then watch guy
John Mayer loves watching got one of the
biggest watch collections in the world
and you know who tonight is Kesha babe
whoa does she have sex with a ghost on
it well funny you should mention it we
we played off of our because we write
according to the guest we played off of
a ghost uh show and I I'm I'm with her
on her show as a psychic medium I like
it and they they electrocute me through
the whole thing and I can't I can't let
on that I'm being electrocuted
well I'm literally calling the spirits
they are shocking my entire body and I'm
like
and I'm like
a ring yeah dude how fun was Kesha is
that she was great she she seems awesome
she was down for it Kesha seems awesome
yeah and we were like doing that thing
we were across the table from each other
like holding in like we couldn't you
can't laugh yeah it's gonna blow the
whole load I can't shut her no but not
this part her music I love her music I
love um um uh Die Young yeah that's all
but all her because I when I was a
physical therapist 2011 2012 he's got
bangers I used to listen to her my love
is your drug love is your drug huge and
then and then
heartbeat yeah tongue
what about that collab with pitbull yes
it's going down
and Tasha is not only an amazing
performance but she's wrote I don't know
which ones but she's wrote some of the
most classic songs of all time she wrote
the national anthem she did yeah she did
she wrote that and she wrote the Hail
Mary in the outfall that not a lot of
people know it cash it's great but the
bigger question is what do you think uh
yeah am I wearing a shirt or a jacket I
think that it's a I think it's versatile
and I think that you could call it
either I got a new name for it when you
were in a shirt that could be a jacket
you know what you're wearing a jacket
jacket or jerk I like a jerk better
actually jerk's the winner asks the uh
ask the bot what it thinks but Thursday
nights 10 o'clock TruTV and TBS right
now we're building momentum you guys are
like here's another thing you do put it
on your DVR yeah put it on your DVR if
you don't watch it live what you want
you to watch it live but if you don't
watch it within three days on the DVD
that's what they count three days after
that's all they count and in practice
you're a Nielsen family watch it and
Impractical Jokers is the show that we
want to see yes the guys have a put deal
and they'll put on another show
regardless what we do want to see the
Impractical Jokers yeah
we're going to see them one way or
another legally contractual yes but but
do that and the tour is on right now and
practical jokers live the tour yes.com
and this week actually we're at
Prudential Center in Newark Newark uh we
are at the dome in Wallingford
Connecticut and we're at the UBS arena
in Long Island all this week wow Niagara
Falls too but and that's just cash is
opening for them in Prudential that's
right now Kesha didn't talk ghosts with
you you didn't ask her about ghosts um
well we talked ghosts like fake because
I I was I was never you didn't earnestly
ask her I don't know I don't think I had
much of a ghost conversation I was too
busy getting electrocuted yeah because
they had to test the electrocution on me
first
what does it feel like bro first of all
first of all I already got electrocuted
in season nine by Adam Pally and John
gabras and they thought it was special
their vacation shows absolutely a
hundred and one places to party before
so I watched it on a plane love it love
those guys but they thought it was so
funny it's the first time we ever it's
the first time we ever brought back
I've seen a lot of things on planes yeah
how much I watch Anthony Bourdain on a
plane yeah rhymed yeah and practical
jokers on a plane yeah for sure
um first time they ever brought
something back so I got electrocuted a
gang again again now let me ask you a
question put shock collars on either
meant for large animals I wanted to
which and they put them all on my legs
and my arms and then they have a control
panel and there's levels that go from
like zero to when the guys were
controlling the intensity of the levels
and dude it is you could never ever get
used to it did you have a diaper on you
could never prepare for it no I actually
though you should have actually I'm
being serious like that that could have
caused an act I I did wonder afterwards
because we didn't check with any any
physician if because they jolted me for
one hour so like afterwards I was just
wondering about my heart yes things like
that but you were fine uh I will tell
you this
and I want to give much away but this is
giving it away but for one of the one of
the bits in the new tour
I come out they don't know this but
under my clothes I'm wearing them and I
do a whole bit and we pull someone up on
audience from the audience and they
electrocute me whenever they want while
I'm doing my bit wow and I've done it
like 10 times 10 times already dude
I gotta go out there with the shock
collars on
right I'm gonna have to pre-test the
levels before we go out there so they
have video of me every single show in
The Green Room testing the levels until
it hurts because yeah the commitment to
the show we made this show interactive
no you made the show interactive and the
new one oh it's a live tour there's like
three or four big interactive videos the
live tour you go the commitment to that
is worth the tickets go go get them but
then the commitment to your actual show
that you do in practical jokers
Thursdays 10 p.m True TV and TBS is kind
of making me feel like how could the
views not be going up week after week
and even if the person making decisions
is treating this just very black and
white you have to put some emotion to it
say despite what it is yeah this is
something your network needs hear us
David zazlov
I wanted to ask you this I actually I
actually thought of this when we were
driving in today would you for the show
get shot in the leg
like a shot with a gun in the wood a
bullet would you get shot if I told you
safely even if this hits the femoral
artery we will save your life well
that's the first thing I thought of was
that order would you get shot by a
sniper where they pinpoint actually they
shoot you right above the kneecap which
you get shot in the leg for a punishment
for the like grand finale of the show
would you let someone shoot you with a
gun absolutely not you would say no to
that I would say no I already have two
Jaden tattoos man like the first one was
enough I was gonna say no to this but
the kid came and posed for it I couldn't
do anything about it right I wouldn't
get shot we already said we actually
have a joke that I'm gonna shoot Harpoon
through Murray's chest for the finale
yeah I told you what we did for the
movie for the movie we wanted to be
terrible and the original punishment for
the movie was that someone was going to
give away a kidney because we wanted it
to be like it's amazing good but bad
right and so and then they told us
legally like the insurance would never
cover that I saw a funny tweet once it
said Impractical Jokers is the
definition of white people [__] really
that was a good tweet I don't think that
yeah we have a large large minority
audience no no no no no definitely no
they oh like we were so crazy exactly no
the Tweet was positive it meant like
white people [__] meaning like they'll
do anything like you know they'll say
why people that's why people [__] skiing
and you know jumping off a building or
something like that it was like that we
did do two skits out of one thousand yes
we do yeah yeah two skiing skits I mean
what is now is this um this is well
Murray just got hit with the Harpoon how
hard is it to fall asleep after being
electrocuted all day good question uh
actually when you come out I actually
have marks on my legs and arms that are
like deep divots still right now
that's a cross that look at this he got
a crucifix tattooed 2003 uh April 2003
road trip to New Orleans Electric
ladyland Tattoo you drove from New York
City to New Orleans in a minivan with
five other people fun
the drive was horrible
the drive was off I get motion sickness
and I was in the back for a portion of
it and it's like driving in the back of
a bus and the kid that was driving was
swaying and I almost vomited shout out
sway by the way sway in the morning God
bless him five fingers to death he'd be
a good guess yeah I would love to sway I
love sway I know you know personally
halfway come on invite sway to the party
please invite him yeah uh so this guy
since I got this it was 60 and I got in
2003 20 years ago about 96 now due to
inflation yeah but I got it and it was
it wasn't symmetrical
and I have OCD and this has bothered me
for 20 years so what he's doing was
Bailey I'll never forget it and I think
they threw me to somebody kind of new
so you didn't get Bailey or Bailey was
the new Bailey was the kid that did it I
wonder if barely conviction
by the way I would never want this right
now I would never want my tribal on my
like what you know about right now and I
would I don't really want the jadens but
I would keep this on my own on Staten
Island I was driving the other day on
Staten Island
I'll show you my um I I record my
drivers because I also I drive an Uber
okay on Staten Island they they have a
tattoo removal place that is brand new
just open they said remove the tattoos
painless tattoo removal if we want to go
do all that business from Pete yeah
removed it's hard that's it's not
painless that's a lie it's more painful
than the tattoo what do you think's more
painful you get an electrocuted by
casual or getting your tattoos removed
it's probably close I'll tell you that
much because it [__] hurts dude you
can't I can't control my audible Yelps
like if I go yeah I do that I'm sorry
sorry I should have warned you but I
know yeah I got it I feel like it's got
electricity yeah
um you know what you're you'd be great
at Sal if if you know if there's a
single guy out there like one of your
friends or whatever you're a great
Matchmaker I think you are one of the
guys who would be able to match make
because both parties would trust you and
say if Sal thinks you two are a good
match and Sal is advocating for this man
advocating for this woman I think out of
all my friends you would be the best
Matchmaker nice compliment in my life I
have Match Made I've since moved away
from it because it's precious it's not
always going to work and then I don't
want the ha if it for some reason
doesn't work at all then I'm putting
myself in a position but you're just
good at it yeah but I've matched many
people that are now married really feel
good multiple that they've they've
stayed because if they get divorced now
it's not your fault no no I've like at
one point I'm putting that marriage in a
basket and sending it down the river
like Moses yeah and then you know yeah
yeah they don't say pect yeah put your
kid in a basket and send it down the
river and you're trying to claim that
you still love this kid yeah you're
trying to give it about trying to do
something helpful to get eaten by an
alligator depends on the currents I'm
not sending my kid down the river unless
I [__] Mr G says I can that's wild
local New York City weatherman reference
remember George Whipple
New York one cat eyebrows like like two
[__] goats but Google George Whipple
my brows
this guy's on the guy's eyebrows were
they literally
[Laughter]
can we name this episode George
Whipple from what I know I think he's
kicking fine you think he's Fully Alive
Google it Uncle George you know I used
to hear about him and now I don't I will
say that yeah because I wonder if his
eyebrows as you age like if you go bald
as you age do the eyebrows ball that's
such a choice I'll tell you what right
now that thickness that kind of fullness
I'll tell you right now I want to see
his baby picture when he came out
because I feel like I feel like if there
was even five percent of that he was a
baby that had huge huge eyebrows that's
the thing it is a choice to grow
eyebrows like that but you could make
that choice and I could make a choice
right now and never get to that level
you could never you can't get to that
level no it's not a choice but it's also
genetic you have to be able to do that
how about this he has to make that
decision like I'm not going to keep up
with this my whole life Let It Go and
it'll be my calling card right because
if I had those I'd be like I need to do
maintenance we need to manage this right
right but he's like no you know what I'm
gonna be I'm just gonna let it fly and
it is a calling card of his yeah no
Jordan
he's alive George what does he look like
now he looks like Jay Leno now oh my God
I haven't seen George Ripple in years
look how long his hair grew he went
fully white haired
insane George Ripple's got hair like a
founding father right why he does look
at those brows look at the Brows he's
got to be in his mid 90s and he looks
fantastic yeah you think he intermittent
fast he probably brow beats the [__] out
of himself yeah
I would you ever have George Whipple on
practical jokers and electrocute him
I'll have anyone on the project was an
electric guitar you know it would be fun
to have George Whipple on Impractical
Jokers and if he loses his thing you
shake his eyebrows shave it oh my God
and we know that you are come on you do
what you got to do you keep them you
don't you shave them either way it's a
story dude you know what would be
[__] awesome at this party we're
doing in New York well what what day
does this come out this comes out on the
9th March 7th two days ago you had this
party yeah you were there everybody was
there advice I had Yolanda Vega greeting
people as they walked in could you
imagine if I
can you can't afford vague I don't know
but nobody can would you let me charge
Yolanda Vega to the no press card and
say I got Yolanda Vega for a big event
for us and she's yelling your London
she's yelling El volcano as everyone
walks in and I said it's five G's but I
put on no pressure you would say I
wouldn't even bat an eyebrow I'm I'm
being serious though I wouldn't you
would be like I'm like I'd be I would be
like that's that's why we have a company
fine worth it that you do it and because
she knows she's a queen and we love her
[__] it I wanna I we want her on the
show guys we've said this in the past if
somebody knows Yolanda Vega because I
she wrote to me she gave me she gave me
that autograph she said she loves the
show but I thought it was a friend of
hers no who gave me that goddamn water I
think Alyssa gave me I gotta talk to my
I gotta get this woman on on we gotta
get her on the next she's royalty if we
decide to do a live hey babe which we
might this year and Yolanda Vega doesn't
introduce us
I don't know why we do the show if we
either we either get you'll we work the
next live show that you and I will do
for hey babe around Vegas schedule you
know what the opening word is the
opening thing she goes for the New York
State Lottery I'm Yolanda babe oh yes
yeah and then if that costs five G's
then that costs five that costs five G's
it's fine yeah and you know what you
know what the thing about Yolanda Vega
is she seems like a person that she
would do that willingly have a good time
and then also I think she's the type of
person she'd come with homemade baked
goods for us she would have baked
something for us and gave it to us I
know Rice Krispie treats I don't know
much about it but I feel like I know
Yolanda Vega is somebody who I guarantee
you her kids literally games she made
big CD she made baked goods she was that
Mom who did that and I guarantee you I'm
right I I would agree with you I would
agree with you yeah yeah now that's a
gig what's a better gig hers or Vanna
White's gotta go Vanna White Vanna White
so what is it 30 when did Wheel of
Fortune come out when she was she a day
one Wheel of Fortune Shadow white has
money like a senator from literally just
flipping she might be the most she's got
Oprah she's got Judge Judy she might
have more money than Pat Sajak and I
would pay Vanna White more than I'd pay
Pat Sajak and I love Pat Sajak I know
I think she's 75. why and she started in
1975 she was the first she was day one
they were the faces of the series yeah
but well because Pat Sajak wasn't the
original uh how old is Savannah White
56.
63 60 mid 60s
she's 65 I said 63 67 the answer 65
right right in the middle yeah first you
said 50 something though remember that
which was ridiculous for me to say yeah
shoot
what's a salary get a new net worth on
her net worth on it we should play the
net worth game that's fun you ready for
Vanna White's ready for Vanna White's
net worth 10 mil her net worth yeah not
salary our salary is a million a year
I'm gonna say net worth you all way out
way wrong I'm gonna guess she's 30 she's
30 plus years at a network gig and she's
you can't can I replace her look out in
the streets because it's going to be
riots can I get it my edit my guess yeah
80 million net worth Vanna White
I think I think she's probably worried
well net worth is tough right because
because like I don't know what kind of
Investments about what you made and what
you've spent in that time right right
you could make five million a year bring
home two and a half over ten years
you're not worth 25 million no because
of the cost of living what you're worth
is what you have in assets so you can
make five million a year for 10 years
make 25 million but only be worth 7
million because you spent the 20. you
understand what I'm saying right so what
she's worth I'll say she's worth 20
million dollars
Venetia pimp what's the answer 85
million holy [__] dude
I mean you're on fire it's on fire
he he's he's on fire NBA Jam wow now
what 85 million what's her that's insane
that's insane and you know how good the
gig is she's still doing it 30 years
she's worth 85 million dollars she's
still going in she's driving in she's
parking she's paying tolls and she
probably has a driver she's still
driving in and she's flipping those
letters and I bet you two I bet you they
have it down to a science where they
film literally for like two months and
it's for the whole year or they do like
Monday Tuesday Wednesday 15 shows what's
the insurance four days a month they
film four days a month tell me who has a
better job no that's Pat Sajak's network
he's worth 15 million dollars less
how did that happen now how did that
happen that's us I think that because
Vanna White first of all Vanna White
she's the one do you think she has her
her wrists
check oh dude I found a white yeah have
Vanna White on practice nobody nobody
come on do you think that she's got uh
Insurance on her wrists I guarantee you
she does I guarantee you she has
insurance can you imagine she could you
imagine she broke her thumb and she how
do you she has to protect her wrists and
hands at all costs how about this Vanna
White follow me here Vanna White
outlasted technology she used to turn
the lettuce now a sudden we got digital
they kept her now she Taps it to reveal
the letter they don't even need her okay
they could have replaced her with no one
a long time ago
I found her hustle I found her hustle
she's a 15 million dollar a year hustle
she just is in charge of casino slot
machine licensing
of her own I think of her own image and
then she started buying out oh wait no
Wheel of Fortune is the the most popular
slot there is but I don't think she's
getting a kickback I think she must be
doing a third party side wheel of
whatever no I'll tell you what I'm
trying to we're trying to get something
I'll tell you what I know you should I
swear to go I'm not joking we talked
like three people already no you need
slot machines if you're out there and
you do slots and I said before call me
because we want to do slime you know
that you are let me let me tell you
something I think that the only person
who has made more money or as much money
by saying as few words there's only two
people in the history of the world who
are multi-multi-millionaires but they
have not they've they haven't said
they've said minimal words Vanna White
Stephen Hawking oh whoa I mean he's a
genius he can't he hasn't talked I
thought you're gonna go with teller who
tell her pen and tell her pen and
teller's another one 40-year top of the
top of the peep uh magician you don't
say Jack okay I met him one time he
spoke he don't say Pat Sajak no he
doesn't say Jack okay
I'm not getting in on that money pan and
Teller Vanna White Stephen Hawking most
money lease wart I agree and uh yeah
that's and uh well Johnny Madame talks
who Molly Matlin maybe she's a she's a
very famous deaf actor oh yeah but
that's yeah that's not the same thing
she doesn't require tape Boy the kid
with the tape over here sure sure that
must be nice not saying anything don't
say anything I mean Vanna what I think
if we're if we're being honest here
though
you still does it four days I think that
is the cushiest four days a week no one
can replace her four days a month she
cannot be replaced she's gonna be
replaced so think about that the two of
them they gotta go out like a blazing
Glory together no one's not gonna do it
without the other but that show's gonna
live on past them it's Gotta it's like
the price is right it's like Jeopardy
keeps going Jeopardy's got I mean we
never thought we'd see a Jeopardy
without say uh without uh Quebec but do
you think that Wheel of Fortune uh uh
like with with Pat Sajak and Vanna White
can continue because it it just feels so
iconically that dude Bob Barker was
replaced by by what's his name wrong it
looks like my father yeah
yeah he's and he's he's really out he's
like a hippie dude now he's got long
hair with sneakers with a suit who Bob
Barker no well no Bob Barker
he yeah he's very relaxed on the show
you know what I don't like and it can
can I if the producers are watching
because I was on pricer I didn't get on
stage I had a funny story I went to
prices right with dom Herrera and Steve
Byrne and my buddy Rob fee and we were
sitting in like the third row Center and
like Drew Carey came out and like just
saw Dom and Steve in the audience
because I didn't know him but he went he
came out and he was like Hey and he went
down Herrera they were friends probably
comedy for 25 years he was what are you
doing here and Don was like I came to
see The Price is Right
didn't get a big laugh yeah I don't
remember but anyway they got they did
away with aisles and seats now they have
everybody in these little pods that are
together I guess it was remnants of
covert they didn't change but now
everybody's sitting at like a like a
little booth together like three or four
people and it's like half the people in
the audience they used to be like come
on down and find and then you said like
side step out of the out of the road for
like five minutes makes it fun and then
run down the island
you know and now they don't encourage
you to do that or people just do that I
think I I don't know I think they
encourage you has anyone ever fallen
down the aisle so many times you got to
watch prices right like [__] ups like
people live on TV have fallen yeah oh
taking headers man yeah yeah but anyway
but but if you pull one up pimpy yeah
just somebody eating it on prices right
so so Savannah though Vanna's four days
a month turn in letters she's an icon
that's that would be the richest person
in the world named Vanna
that I know of what about this
you think she hates it I do think she do
you think like no no there's no room for
hate here I come in four days a month
I'm family with this these people and
this has made me I'm I'm as rich as a
person any person could be and she
doesn't even have there's no guesswork
when somebody says the letter it lights
up she touches it that's all you have to
do right because in the past maybe shoes
that will be like a uh you should have
to listen you don't have to listen if
she doesn't want to she just see as long
as she can see the light she touches it
yeah has there ever been a time where
the light it lit up and she didn't and
the letter didn't come on my screen she
had to hit it like an old TV
honestly if I was them I would go back
to the turning
we know you don't need it but we
appreciate it yeah going to Styles go
old school go a ridge what's the point
turn the lettuce yeah yeah I um I was
gonna say something else about a
television show oh I don't know go ahead
continue I went to the Maury Povich Show
is the only one that I this episode is
brought to you by better help that's
right I love it better help you and I
use it we talked we were talking about
in the car ride over I was telling you
about my therapist and how helpful he is
all that better help my dad tampatoni's
on better help now that's right
everybody's using Better Home you would
tell me how you had one that you didn't
like and then you switched I switched it
was it was easy to do it it's and that's
it it's just a simple you talk you take
the questionnaire yeah they they team
you up with who they think would be best
for you and whatever problems you may
have you know because mental health is
very serious and it literally better
help it's like life-changing the best
part you don't have to go to an office
everything is done online comfort of
your own home private and it's literally
if you've ever abandoned benefited from
there from therapy you're going to
benefit from this yeah and it's just
it's not just about like I've a problem
it's about finding a deeper like a
knowledge of yourself and self-awareness
it's always changing right yes so my set
of problems last year not my set of
problems this year my thoughts and the
things that I'm worried about are things
that I you know I need to just kind of
get through and work through are always
changing I told you you changed and I
told them we had a meeting about it I
know we didn't changed yes and but
better help is helping you change back
to the to the to that to that old self
if you're still going to start in
therapy yeah uh give better help but try
it's entirely online like you said uh
you fill out that questionnaire and you
get matched with a therapist you could
switch therapists at any time whenever
you want no additional charge
immediately and you don't have to give a
reason you just switch it up baby better
help wants to help you can ghost the
therapist if you want ghost them do
whatever you need right now if you go to
betterhelp.com that's help
betterhelp.com hey babe you're gonna get
10 off your first month that's better
help.com slash hey babe 10 off your
first month please try just have you
ever left your cart
full and abandon it online because all
of a sudden you got hit with the
shipping costs and you were like no way
this isn't worth it then you should know
about ship station in a landscape where
free and fast shipping is the norm it
can be hard for smaller e-commerce
businesses to compete with these big
places and I'm not going to name who
they are you know who they are so you
keep yourself competitive with ship
station if you have a small business you
ship station you can lower your shipping
costs you can make returns easy keep
your customers happy all the time you
save from automating your shipping tests
keep your business growing all year long
give that self yourself that extra time
okay there's a free trial and it's quick
setup now this is what you're gonna do
it makes it easy to grow your business
it handles your orders from every
Marketplace in one single dashboard it
effortlessly integrates everywhere you
sell online including Amazon Etsy eBay
Shopify and all those okay you manage it
from One dashboard you automate your
routine shipping tasks you print
shipping labels you easily compare rates
and delivery times and automate delivery
notification locations this is the job a
full-time job of a person that's being
automated and brought to you very
conveniently by ship station with the
best discounts in the industry you'll
never worry about overpaying get up to
84 off USPS and UPS rates and if that's
not enough use our promo code to try
ship station free for two months keep
growing your business all year long with
ship station use promo code hey babe
today at shipstation.com to sign up for
your free 60-day trial that's
shipstation.com promo code hey babe
however one two and I went to Amore
apartment show I think they were doing
it in Stanford Connecticut and I was at
one where he was um he was not the
father oh you were really really a big
one where he was not the father and it
was like the entire crowd this woman was
so convinced he was the father she was
like I have not had sex with anyone in
10 years other than you so this cannot
this is so she was just hedging a bet
like she went full in and then he goes I
am not the father and then I swear to
Christ this is an episode she goes it's
your brother
oh yeah and it became another I think I
think what happened was they they I
don't think they outright lie but first
of all they started producing that [__]
it all started with Springer and then
Steve yeah Steve Wilkos Steve Wilkos who
still does a show I think he still does
his show there's a I just did I did New
York comedy club of Stanford Connecticut
which is a really good club in Stanford
and I drove past The Steve Wilkos studio
so when that when Jerry Springer hit
that was you could that was like girls
gone it was like the it was like number
one it was selling Greatest Hits Jerry
Springer Greatest Hits DVDs do you
remember that yes and then so they got
to the point where they knew they were
going to fight right what I think is
they produce them and coax them to be
like you say that you know we don't know
but if it if it's like it's his brother
that's crazy is it his brother you know
what I mean yeah so you think it's all
okay I think in the beginning they used
to swing but then I think like now it
becomes now you see like they go to hit
each other but they hold like you could
tell they're not really going at it in
the beginning though there was a few
where they really went at it they really
went at it yeah that that shows is Jerry
Springer on is that not a thing anymore
no because how are they supposed to to
compete with Tick Tock yeah it doesn't
it just it's even Girls Gone Wild it's
like what's the point of that that went
out the window because well because it
was oh because it was under any jails
isn't that guy isn't that guy on the
lamp yeah who's the guy he was a creep
yeah Guys Gone Wild
oh start it that's a great no-pressed
brand yeah okay that's the new shows
youtube.com
these guys are going wild it's like
tropical music plan we all have
daiquiris
oh dude how about this I was flying home
I forgot to tell you this I was flying
this would have been two weeks ago now
but really yesterday or two yeah
yesterday I was flying home the person
in the aisle across me started
projectile vomiting all over the TV
screen in front of in front of them no
so here's one of course yeah so I'm I'm
sitting here in the aisle what airline
uh this was uh you know uh uh Delta okay
so I'm sitting I'm sitting on the TV
yeah we're both aisle seats so I'm you
know I could touch them
all of a sudden you hear we're all
eating
like that and it was like the person in
front of them no no no no no no no it
just hit the screen in front of them so
it didn't hit anybody but who saw it
well I saw it and it happened to be that
nobody was sitting next to him so me and
my partner they watched 101 places to
party before you die yes okay
watching Impractical Jokers because each
week it just keeps getting more and more
viewers so and so so oh that's gross
dude how did you okay what do you feel
do you have a responsibility now that
person knows you saw right do you feel a
responsibility to make them feel okay
about it or can you even keep in your
own disgust what happens it takes me
through your mind well first of all I
was literally in the middle I was in the
middle of eating I had got a uh egg I
got an onion uh egg quiche that's what
they know well quiche was good it wasn't
bad actually it had raw yeah I liked it
beating the quiche and I'm chewing the
quiche they start projecting vomiting I
go are you okay like I I looked almost
like are you are you okay because I was
eating the guy from Silence of the Lambs
in the basket so so I swear he's going
he's gone yeah he's got it just it's
just what I was watching on the show
it's disgusting and I said okay and then
with that the flight attendant comes
over so I'm kind of out of it just
listening whatever he was went up to the
bathroom cleaned himself off comes back
it smells like
it's dead it did it did it smelled like
it smelled it smelled some alcohol he
was definitely drinking the night before
which is fine that smell though went
away so quickly they came out with a uh
on it like that grammar school yes like
the flakes yeah and that takes the smell
away like almost instantaneancy but it
was rough I'm not gonna lie it was rough
you might have bought that product stood
the test of time yeah they used to pull
that when I was in kindergarten when
someone vomited Delta they're still
doing it for you they do so so then oh
an hour goes by the television down
though flight attendant he moved to the
seat next to him because MD that's what
I said it was empty so God blessed be
him he got he just moved to the seat
next time while they were doing that and
then he sat in that seat for the
remainder of the time and then he was
fell asleep a little bit then when he
woke up he said like he got up and like
kind of leaned to us he goes um you know
I'm terrible was he profusely
apologizing so so sorry he said
you know it happens the guy next to me
was sleeping I said ah it happens man
and I go uh and and he was like he goes
yeah he goes I was eating my breakfast
he says to me goes do not watch Anthony
Bourdain Vienna episode don't watch that
he really thinks he puked from watching
something because he said he said I was
eating the breakfast he had the same
thing as I did the quiche and eating the
breakfast and he goes don't watch you
know the Anthony it was the Anthony
Bourdain sausage no what happened was he
said I was watching it they're doing an
episode in the end I was like I love
Vienna he's like watching it they're
talking about sweets whatever he goes
and then they go to a farm and they're
I'm watching the episode he goes in out
of nowhere the guy that Anthony
Bourdain's talking to a goat runs by he
grabs the going ahead lock slits his
throat then they cut to him turning the
goat upside down bleeding it and they
cut open the goat's stomach and start
pulling his organs out and then the next
cut is them eating the organs
and then I vomited everywhere and I was
like yep he didn't vomit until that part
that's when he vomited he had a lot of
time to change a channel walk away no it
was building up so why didn't he get the
bag out because it just came over him
and and also he had the full tray it's
tough to gr you can't move when you're
in the trash Oh God that is vomited
everywhere and I was like I would throw
there's no way I wouldn't have thrown up
there's no way I've done it I've thrown
out when people throw up yeah oh and
then on that same flight uh flight
attendant uh the flight attendant um the
head guy he was like a gay guy made an
announcement he goes um whoever stole
um there was a cell phone
out up by the by the bathroom by the
flight attendants whoever took that cell
phone there will be no repercussions
there will be no nobody will call the
police but we do need that cell phone
back whoever stole that he was like it
was an OtterBox cell phone so I'm hoping
someone came up and be like I totally
thought this was my cell phone as as
what I know nobody claim nobody said
that somebody stole that guy's phone or
he [__] he put it up his ass I don't
know wow that's that's
that he took that upon himself to make
that announcement and to put that out
there I think that was why he wanted his
phone I guess it was his ass it must
have been I mean who he's not going to
do that for somebody else you believe it
when do you would you if you took it and
he was like we need it no repercussions
and you're like I could say I thought it
was mine holy [__] I have an OtterBox
too or do you believe that when you get
up there and give it there's gonna be no
repercussions
he said it is a verbal contract but I
got to think that that person even if
they're having a crisis of conscience
they're going to think he might turn up
imagine that there's no reason that
somebody from the from the coach is just
a coach it's like how do I legally know
there won't be any repercussions
but how would I 100 how can I guarantee
right how can that person guarantee you
go I would have been like is this it on
the floor dude did I ever tell you I was
at Casey Joseph's bachelor party in in
New Orleans and we went to uh not went
to time New Orleans when you drove and
got that tattoo a different one A
different time yes we went and we we
went to a laser tag place right there's
like 20 guys right and we rented out a
whole one of the whole rooms ourselves
it was actually it was like laser tag
but it was like uh arcade it was it was
a big compound right and we left we wore
Coke and hookers at the laser yeah they
were cooking hookers there and a
bachelor party we were shooting the
focus with laces yes
so so there was like this entry there's
a there's like a room before the room
right so it's not outside you go in this
room it's like a holding room like this
and that's where all the jackets are in
the guns and you put it on and you get
into the mood and the lights are neon
and people are telling you okay this is
you press this once and you go in right
and they tell them so we leave they
leave all your jackets and bags here
this is safe everyone comes in here but
actual jackets not not jerks no not
shirts not shackles jackets so everyone
leaves that stuff in we going it's a
goddamn blast we come out like a half
hour later whatever is they rank you
it's all that we go we get our stuff
together all of a sudden Casey's phone
is not in his jacket right and he's like
my phone is gone and he looks through
everyone looks through everyone the
phone is gone so he's like this is
insane like I need my [__] I need my
you you can't lose your phone right and
especially on your bathroom it was there
okay so we ripped the room apart it's
not there what are we gonna do what are
we gonna do we go to the people we're
like my phone was there it's not there
someone came in here and had to have
taken it and they were like okay we have
we have we have cameras so we all go
into the that's awesome we all go into
into this booth with the security guard
and we're watching we'll watch you and
watching sure as [__] a [__]
middle-aged woman just walks in there
closes the door behind her walks up well
now she we don't see her inside there
but she walks in close the door and then
she comes out and it's and we watch her
do it we shoot an employee no she wasn't
an employee right so we're like holy
[__] [__] like we can't believe we
caught the person he's actually witness
how about this she's still there so we
see her there we have her on the tape
right so everyone's like what are we
gonna do what are we gonna do she's
still here like this is [__] crazy
was she playing laser tag she was there
with her kid bro right and so we're like
this is going to come to a head how does
this work itself out she's here we do we
confront her and then the place was like
we don't want to confront her we're
going to call the police
they call the police they were like well
what if she leaves she we can't we can't
really hold it back but I don't know so
then everyone goes and stays at all the
doors because we want to make sure that
we don't lose this is a good that's a
party
so we're waiting at all the doors that
everyone's watching us she has no idea
like 20 something people know and then
the cops arrive and they tell her what
happened and they approach the woman and
they're like look we have you on camera
taking a cell phone she denies it right
she's like I didn't do it I didn't do it
she's like listen we have you on camera
getting the cell phone she's like I I
didn't do anything I'm here it was her
son's birthday bro right and at first we
were like [__] this woman like who does
that she was a regular woman like she
just walked in and stole someone's cell
it's like somebody's literally
somebody's mom yeah like what are you
doing right what are you doing yeah you
know so so then um so the cop the woman
goes listen I you have a choice I can
search you right here right now or I
could search you in the bathroom and
she's like I don't I don't have it she's
like let's go she takes her into the
bathroom in the stool and the woman
comes out with it the police officer
comes out she denied it till the end it
was in the woman's [__] yeah it was in
her [__] and she denied it till the end
and then it took a little coaxing but
she got it out I kind of respected she
wrote she wrote with it to the end I do
respect a little bit yeah it took a
little you had to get it ready to come
out like they she read a passage from a
romance novel it came out yeah and then
the cop comes out with it and she said
what do you want to do like do you want
to press charges and he didn't press
charges which I would have done the same
kid's birthday yeah did she apologize
anything nothing uh I think she I don't
think she really apologized I think she
was like she's a kleptomaniac yeah I I
gotta call Casey because I don't
remember exactly but I think she was
just like
she just gave it and then call him went
back
let's call why not if we're gonna do it
let's let's see if Casey by the way who
sings the theme song of the hey babe
intro you hear every week which is going
to be changed by Sal's voice recording
that's right who directed Impractical
Jokers oh and the director of
Impractical Jokers Casey has been with
us since day one in Impractical Jokers
uh what he was a writer then he became a
head writer and then now he is directing
the show and he's killing it absolutely
killing you know we love butcher box we
shot it from the mountaintops okay you
want High Quality Meats delivered right
to your door monthly cancel at any time
they do all the work for you you get
that peace of mind because you're
getting high Quality Meats and Seafoods
you can trust they I mean we're talking
100 grass-fed beef wild caught Seafood
free range organic chicken everything
humanely raised no antibiotics or
hormones delivered to your doorstep
cancel ship uh trips to the to the
supermarket your time is money this free
shipping always you can curate the boxes
to what you like or choose from
pre-selected boxes I mean it can't be
more convenient uh butcherbox came into
my life and I have never bought meat
again at the supermarket it just comes
every month I cancel I pause anytime I
need it's really wonderful uh exclusive
member deals all the time okay get free
listen to the deal they're doing right
now free chicken nuggets for one year
and 10 off your first box when you sign
up today okay that's a 22 ounce bag of
gluten-free chicken nuggets in every
single order for a year on them when you
sign up at butcherbox.com hey babe and
use code hey babe and that's on top of
the 10 of your first box claim the deal
today at butcherbox.com hey babe and use
code hey babe we love butcherbox
I um and uh Casey Jones uh good boy
Casey Jose pulls off Salt and Pepper the
only two people who pull up salt and
pepper are him in my Cannon him and my
Canon are two beautiful salt and pepper
boys they should be actually the new
salt and pepper he's he's so good his
hair is amazing best hair in the game
amazing hey baby uh we're doing hey babe
right now hi Casey this is Chris
DiStefano live babe we have on the phone
Casey Jose aka the writer and performer
of the hey babe theme song and the new
song and the new Salt and Pepper with
him and Mike Kenneth so on pepper King
and also the director of the show yes I
was telling the story about your
bachelor party and how we were at laser
tag and the woman stole your cell phone
and we caught it on uh we caught on the
security cameras and we called the cops
and we blocked the exits and we
confronted her and then the cop took her
into the bathroom now I don't exactly
remember the ending there like the cop
took her into the bathroom and I know
that you didn't press charges you're a
good guy you're a good guy what a great
head on your shoulders and a kind heart
but did she show remorse because wasn't
she denying it until the very end until
they pulled it out of a [__] in the
stall
it was out of her titty okay
it really was it was in a bra a bra yeah
there's a couple of things all right so
you know can you tell can you tell the
story in your own words
did you talk about like how she was
there for her son's birthday yes yes we
did okay good you did a good job then
okay um and we got it on video but we
didn't have video inside the room when
she took your phone out of your jacket
right we had her on video going in and
coming out no we got her on video taking
it out oh I didn't even remember that oh
yes that's right because when we saw it
we erupted in the in this right we were
like holy [__] like it's crazy to
solve a crime that just happened yeah
we saw the crime dude it just happened
sometimes does a crime happen to you and
like within 10 minutes you saw as soon
as you saw it you went all you heard was
investigate yeah yes okay so tell us
okay all right so we first of all it's
my bachelor party and we go to play
laser tag and because you guys because
here's one thing I know about you and
your friends you guys [__] yeah
yeah we don't I know strip club just
laser tag yep
but there were cocaine and hookers yeah
the bezel the 50 mile an hour ones yeah
yeah yeah which is like cocaine and
hooker yeah so I we all go to play laser
tag and then suddenly
um as we're like hanging around the
place I realized like oh my phone's not
in my little I think it was like I had a
little fanny pack as I do and it wasn't
in there and I was like oh what's going
on I ask around there no one knows and
for some reason I you know I think my
brother Colin was like why don't we see
if they have security cameras so we go
back there and they're like oh we do
this is like now 45 minutes to an hour
later after we had even done this also
shocked that she was still there because
she's like she's whoever took it is gone
they're not gonna take it and linger
they have to know that there might be
security cameras do you understand I'm
I'm please keep telling it but I'm I'm
remembering now it was I swear to God
one of the most exciting moments of my
life you you don't you're never in this
situation never never Justice Swift
Justice immediate card it's like the
wild west oh God continue
right
see a woman take it and we're all like
Jaw to the floor and then in that moment
someone in like our party runs out right
on hey babe weaves and comes back in and
goes she's still here
wow oh my God oh my God
so then it was like a Miracle on Ice so
the police come she pulls it out of her
titty and then does she deny does she
apologize does she do anything remorse
she went into the bathroom right she was
denying it till the end and then the cop
yeah go ahead so this is really
important because thankfully like like a
a female police officer comes and she's
like immediately she's like feels caught
she's like I have to go to the bathroom
and so she goes
and and the police officers like has a
hunch and like won't let her close the
door because he like you know she kind
of knew that she would probably take the
phone out and try to flush it right I
thought she brought her into Checker but
the woman insisted she had to go to the
bathroom that's right right trying to
get out of it trying to flush the
evidence you know what I mean right like
so so she goes into the bathroom and she
goes to sit to pee and then she's like
she sees her kind of pull it out and
she's like no don't throw it out like I
see you you know and so she comes out
and that might have been a crime
actually though watching through the
stall oh yeah probably violated him
right there so we should probably follow
up so then so then once you come down
she kind of apologizes and this is the
thing she apologized and she said oh uh
the devil got up in me that's right
and that's the name of this episode The
Devil got up in me
and and I forgot because we lost our
[__] when she said that I was like [__]
her in the devil yeah you you had the
best response you were just like oh
really the devil got into you
do you remember how how mad I was I
think I even left you a voicemail that
you might have saved where I was Furious
and like [__] her
Sal you were you were egregious Philbin
yes
maybe that's the name of the episode
wait Casey so she actually did apologize
to you in the group though
she yeah she did she like she said yeah
she basically was like um because
because the officer was like in front of
her was like do you want to press
charges and I went through all this in
my head and I was like there's no way
I'm coming down to like this weird like
outside of New Orleans town to like to
like appear in court over like an iPhone
5 right so so I was like no I was like
just just don't do it again and please
set a better example for your son who
who was like running around just like
trying to enjoy his birthday it was his
birthday it wasn't even his birthday
party it was just him she took her son
to this to this like uh arcade which is
for adults anyway I don't know why kids
were there it's so sad and no there was
there was some kids [__] there wasn't
that no it was all kids
it was it was really sad but like give
me a [__] break now like like own it
just own it be like you know what I'm in
a bad way you know what I have a
compulsion I'm gonna shoot you straight
I'm completely honest I'm mortified this
is never happened to me I won't do it
again could you find it in your heart to
show a little Mercy to [__] pull
religion into it pissed me off I was
like I was mad I said if she would have
told you straight up I say don't press
charges I said but she said the devil
got enough [__] you press charges I
don't care right but then I felt bad for
the Sun so then she and then and then
the police just let her go oh really the
devil got into you on your son's
birthday at the arcade yeah the devil
found yeah yeah that was the same
response that the guy who killed four
students in Idaho said he goes sorry the
devil got up exactly yeah yeah this
devil seems like all over the place it
gives it something like the ability to
play guitar really well and it also
makes make someone take a phone and put
it in their tits yeah yeah it's like
it's oldest trick in the book put the
phone in the tits well actually you guys
should have actually known since it's
about she should have known that it's a
batch upon he said I'm the stripper and
then started pulling the phone and then
it becomes any sense and she says one of
you guys hired me yeah and then kind of
turns it on you where's my money steals
even more and then she goes and who
wants to play the devil right now yes
and get up that would have been smart
and get up in there right yeah and then
you guys would have said we can't do it
right now we have bowling next exactly
right yeah the ball next it was midnight
bowling with bumpers and yes let me ask
you a question what did you feel in the
moments after catching her and knowing
she was there
remember we remember we stood at the at
the exits like I was like I'm not
letting a leaf yeah you know because if
she's gonna go leave I'm just gonna be
like but what was because I know how
excited I was and I if I recall
correctly were you as excited as Mia
were you not as excited as me I think we
took separate cars when we left but I
was yeah I was so like jazzed it was
like getting off a rollercoaster
adrenaline rush dude right right and you
left me a voicemail like just to be fun
and I wish I wonder if I kept it I think
you did because I think years later you
told me you had it oh I gotta look I
gotta look if you ever find that patreon
drop it in right now that's on the
patreon yeah but but I think like yeah
you left it in just a paraphrase it you
were just like it was a [__] that stole
Casey's phone you know or something like
that it was like yeah get it out get me
out your titties or something like that
but I was so I was just so do you
remember though this was also we tried
to go to a gun range as well do you
remember that yeah what happened there
all right so that was crazy too because
the guy tried to like really upsell us
on like this gun range and we left while
we're talking people were just walking
in with loaded shotguns pointed at our
faces just passing through there was
like no regulation all of us got so
freaked out it was in the sticks of New
Orleans they tried to upsell us and like
I've never been to a I've never shot a
gun in my life but other people had and
they're all like that can't be right and
every time they were like that can't be
right the number came down a little bit
they were like this is so sketchy and
the fact that people were coming in City
slick is coming from a mile away yeah
he's like let me show you my Magic
Bullets yeah I'll say I'll say would you
like a Magic Bullet
a different kind of Southerner that's it
yeah I don't know I just got a Foghorn
Leghorn but God bless him all right well
I'm glad that you were there to answer
the call
oh always man I'm always I'm always
curious and to the woman that took it if
you're listening we know that you are we
know that you are
make a better example for yourself and
your son yeah all right yeah have your
son listen to Hey babe every every uh
Thursday and watching practical jokers
Thursdays at 10 p.m on TBS entry TV
we're looking for ratings
I honestly might before I'll go before I
go the only thing I think bit like my
message to the woman is don't be a fake
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid don't
be ashamed don't hesitate to say hey
babe
if you have a microphone please drop it
I don't even know if I knew every word
like that that was he wrote it that was
I mean the fact that he said I don't
know what happened the devil got up in
me I mean that's the name of the episode
this episode has to be called the devil
got up in me yeah the devil got up in me
or Shack it oh [__] that is
yeah it's one of those things where
because it because you're a piece of
[__] you know because if she is
religious then she's using that religion
as a scapegoat and that's not good for
anybody have you ever stolen anything
like willingly stolen something yeah but
not as an adult no as a teen yeah no oh
he's probably less yeah yeah see that's
the thing if you're stealing as an adult
it's a real issue I might have taken
like I might have went to the get a
refill on a soda more than I should have
right that I might still do but as a kid
I told somebody's but yeah that's it's
has there never been a moment where the
devil got up inside you know who said
the devil got in him you remember Tyga
yeah well he dated I think he dated the
girl who's uh Jenna right not to be
confused with Tigger remember there was
Tigger who hosted 106 in park or BT show
and then tiger right big ticket and I
thought they were the same person
but it's Tyga I think he's saying rack
city right yes is that rack city [__]
rack rack city yeah by the way all of
that song great anyway tiger I think got
caught having sex with like a uh a man
or a woman that was uh biological male
became a woman
transitioned into a woman I don't know
if it was or a trans woman yeah it might
have been a trans woman and and then I
think he his reason was that the devil
was was the devil was or maybe he said
that he didn't do it but the reason he's
getting accused for it is because the
devil's working overtime got it yeah
yeah look it up look it up Tyga says the
devil is working overtime he's a top
earner on only fans I've heard that
Tigers he's having sex with women on
only fans uh yes got it oh so he went
from rapping to having sex on only fans
but he's doing both
who's who's buying Tigers only fans
isn't that really a male based thing to
females no women women so people are
paying money only fans benatia vanity
has a friend on only fans
okay that's public knowledge take us
through it don't you have a friend who's
on only fans oh that friend yes who's
like very isn't she does she have an
only fans we shouted it out on Chrissy
Chaos on a patreon episode oh it's a
patreon episode sorry but what guys are
on there oh is it gay men that pay I
can't see a woman I'm paying Tyga a
recurring subscription fee because once
you see him have sex once can't you just
be like all right I saw it it's the same
difference as a podcast like I guess I
don't know
if you listen to it so Tyga is doing
okay and he's a top earner that's what
I've I've read I I've read that he's a
top earner with bad bad baby right from
Dr Phil yeah big big money yeah I heard
that that was like yeah but anyway but
you've never find the devil for
something in your own life I don't think
I have
I don't think I have you wow the only
way seriously the only way you have free
will the only way honestly at this point
in my mother who's very religious would
admit to this the only way that the
views wouldn't keep going up on
Impractical Jokers if the devil was
working overtime
if they didn't go up week to week if I
would say devil working don't you think
God and the devil are always working
overtime I think that's a hard job I
think they're one in the same I think
you look at it here's the glass half
empty is it is it half full I think
everybody's I think you look at one
thing and you say you know look at how
horrible this is to another group of
people they say that was Jesus helping
us out I think that it's awesome it's
all in the perspective beautiful but
look if you believe in the devil
if you believe in God you have to
believe in the devil believe in both you
have to believe in both if you believe
in one yes I I just to a bit I I don't
believe in religion I had a bit of I
don't believe in religion because I
don't want to believe in the devil so if
I don't want to believe in the devil
then I can't believe in God that's
basically the premise now when you die
in the afterlife how are you going to
explain that
how are you going to explain that I hope
there's an afterlife but but do you
think you're getting into the good point
if you're out here not believing
oh
oh you say I'm not doing what I'm
supposed to do my question is the second
coming my question is do you say if you
get to the Gates of Heaven yeah and he
says to live life as a good person and
Jesus says to you God says to you Sal
explain to me explain to me and he shows
you all the times you denounced religion
every single time you denounce from the
time you're a baby to the time you died
as in 121. so now this is a rough word
to just say that I choose not to believe
after I went it was raised Catholic I
went to Catholic School from preschool
to senior of college so I don't believe
but anyway and he's standing there with
kantanaka because you know she's in yeah
with Kane Tanaka probably has a high
position yeah I think it might be
Treasurer but even Kane Tanaka Maybe
Can't advocate for you right and he says
to you Jesus the great great God says to
you what what are you going to say what
are you going to say to explain it yeah
I think you're a genuine only response
to him has to be
the devil got up in me yeah got to be
right that's all you say I'm sure he
hears that all the time yeah that's like
a hack excuse It's low hanging four
here's what you do or you say I meant
every word I said I meant every word I
said you piece of [__] God kick him in
the genitals whatever they may be press
the elevator say I'm putting myself down
here you look him right in the eye you
say this has been hey babe
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid don't
be ashamed don't hesitate to say hey
babe hey babe hey babe
[Music]